all right so as we discussed we're gonna
start off with the most basic question
how do airplanes fly it's a very
critical question I think everybody
should know the answer to this going
back to the comic that Meenakshi had
with Calvin and Hobbes and not knowing
how airplanes fly I'm thinking that it's
magic is not the way that any MIT
students should be so we're gonna cover
how airplanes fly and we're actually
gonna go beyond what the FAA requires
you to know because frankly you should
know how airplanes fly so just so that
we have a common vocabulary with which
to discuss we're going to talk a little
bit about airplane parts so here in my
my little airplane it's kind of a model
there so you can see that at the at the
front you have your your propeller and
so the engine the propeller and this
little plane is up here at the front
who knows what a fuselage is just shout
it out
the middle part the body that's where
the passengers sit yeah so that that
whole middle part where people sit so if
you're thinking about a big jet engine
it's where all the rows of seats are
where everybody sits that tube in the
middle is called the fuselage and the
wings stick out the side so the middle
part is a fuselage and then one thing
that's interesting is that the tail
actually has a lot more components
people kind of casually refer to it as
the tail but there's a vertical part
that comes up in the back of the
vertical part of the tail can actually
tilt side to side and then you have a
flat horizontal part and that actually
has a back part that can go down and up
and so we're going to talk about what
all of these are so the the back
vertical part when it goes side to side
is your rudder the flat part is your
elevator that you can move up and down
it allows you to control the airplane we
also have of course the the wings
sometimes there are struts that support
the wings so they go from the wing down
to that fuselage and then you have a
landing gear in this case you have these
wheels down at the bottom we're also
going to talk to you during this course
about sea planes so they have slightly
different landing gear but this is a
good good place to start okay the other
thing that we need to talk about are
just the the main four forces that are
on an airplane so they're they're pretty
straightforward so the the force going
up is lift and that force is opposed by
the downward force of weight okay and
then when you're moving the airplane
forward that's thrust and it is opposed
by drag so what we're going to talk
about is that in order for an airplane
to go up the lift has to exceed the drag
in order for the airplane to go forward
the thrust has to exceed the dress
excuse me the lift has to exceed the
weight and the thrust has to exceed the
drag so those are the the main four
forces we're gonna be working with today
so now I'm gonna spend a little bit time
over here on the blackboard
video folks platform they said this way
boy this one's better
yeah fancy colored truck alright
shocks of color alright okay so I will
preface the discussion about lift with
the fact that there are a lot of
theories of lift out there some of which
are wrong so if you spend some time
googling lift before coming here you
might have actually found a couple
scenarios that are completely false so
we're gonna focus on what's true but I
will cover at least one of those false
theories to make sure you guys don't get
hung up on that so in order to talk
about it we're going to think about an
an airplane and we're gonna do a
cross-section of the airplane so if you
took a saw and you cut off the wing what
are what are you left with I don't do it
this way so if you cut off the wing at
the front of the wing is the leading
edge the back of the wing is the
trailing edge if you did it if you cut
that off what does it look like
so it looks like this and this shape is
called an airfoil and we'll get into the
specifics later but first we'll just
we'll talk about a simple way to
understand how lift works so if this is
the the wing and you have air coming in
the air is pushed down by the shape of
this wing so that means as as air flows
by it gets pushed down now what is air
air is not nothing air has molecules it
has mass so if you think about
conservation of momentum this is I think
the easiest way to think about lips so
conservation of momentum you have a
bunch of air pal air molecules and those
air molecules are pushed down so you
have mass being pushed down so if mass
is being pushed down for conservation of
momentum
something must be pushed up and that's
the wing so that's the easiest way to
think about it that if you're deflecting
the air downward in order to have
conservation of momentum the mass of the
wing is lifted upwards we're gonna break
that down but I think that's a good
place to start I'm just gonna take one
moment to talk about an incorrect theory
of lift so let me emphasize it's wrong
one of them is called equal transit
theory has anyone heard about this
getting a lot of head nods okay it's
wrong
equal transit theory which is incorrect
says that basically a molecule of air
that's coming over that starts over here
at the front has to go around the bottom
and meet the tail at the same time that
a molecule that goes over the top has to
meet it at the back there is no physical
principle that says that it is false and
in fact we have measured that they don't
the molecules that go under the bottom
of the wing versus the top of the wing
don't actually reach the end at the same
time but in this false theory equal
transit Theory they say that you have to
reach the bottom at the same time they
also say that there is more distance
basically to cover because of the shape
of the airfoil so in order for the
molecules going over the top to reach at
the same time as the molecules over the
bottom they have to go faster and so
since the air is moving faster over the
top and the bottom that's what creates
lift so that's false and there are many
reasons why it's false you know the
biggest one being that there's there's
no physical principle that says that two
molecules starting at the same time one
going over the top and one going over
the bottom reaches the end at the same
time that's just not true
and we'll show you some more diagrams
that show in fact it doesn't happen the
molecules don't reach at the same time
anyway so please despite that being very
widely propagated that is not true
and please don't spend time on that that
theory all right so let's focus on what
is true how does it really work actually
let me give you one more reason why
that's false the real reason that equal
transit theory is trying to tell you
that that generates lift is that because
of the shape of the airfoil the shape of
the wing that's why the distance that it
has to travel is different over the top
versus the bottom but one reason that's
wrong can you pass me that paper
airplane please who has built a paper
airplane before
okay I see at least two people who
didn't raise their hand do we need to do
a class exercise if you have not filled
a paper airplane it's really important
that you do just as it as a general
childhood experience here's a paper
airplane thank you
you know actually for building it for me
if we took this paper airplane instead
of this this fancy this fancy airplane
and we did a cross-section of this wing
what would it look like yes you
demonstrated with your hands but shout
it out yeah maybe the same at the top of
the bottom top in the bottom it's just a
piece of paper exactly it's just like a
little flat rectangle so instead of this
fancy shape that you have here we're
knees red for wrong okay it's like a
little rectangle right that's what the
paper airplanes cross-section of its
wing looks like well surprise surprise
as you said it's the same at the top at
the bottom so the distance that a air
molecule would have to travel over the
top and the bottom is identical so
really the equal transit Theory
completely falls apart yet a paper
airplane still flies so why is that the
case again remember the actual reason is
that if this paper airplane is inclined
it is pushing air down so air that's
coming up is bumping into it and being
pushed down and therefore as you deflect
air molecules down conservation of
momentum the wing is lifted up all right
so now we're going to break this down in
a little bit more detail and we gonna go
back over here to the slides so one
thing that's important you know as I
said a really detailed mathematical
description is not really necessary to
fly a plane or become a pilot the FAA
doesn't require some of this detail but
it is important to know it to the extent
that it helps you control the airplane
and fly it so here's a good reference in
terms of that but one of the biggest
things is just that for a lift you have
to increase that downward momentum of
the air and air foils are this shape
which is called an airfoil is it is a
type of shape that is very efficient at
increasing that downward momentum now
who knows what Bernoulli's principle is
who's heard of Bernoulli's good
everyone's heard of Bernoulli can anyone
articulate Bernoulli's principle yes
like D plus one-half MV squared equals
constant indifferent squared so when the
pressure goes down somewhere
speed of the particle has to go up yes
absolutely absolutely so so what
Bernoulli observed was the case that
when there is a decrease in pressure
there's an increase in velocity that's
the the core concept that you have to
understand and so when we think about an
airfoil when we see that and I'll draw
another airfoil for us to talk about
[Applause]
when we have air that's moving very fast
over the top of the wing that means you
know an increase in velocity means
there's a decrease in pressure so this
is the extent to which you really need
to know it for the FAA exam so which
statement relates to Bernoulli's
principle I'll let you read those
answers
so is it a B or C shout it out
C good job well done okay we're gonna
discuss a little bit more details though
[Applause]
in order for any wing to generate lift
it has to be in a fluid if this airplane
was in space or in a vacuum and there
wasn't any fluid passing by it then
there wouldn't be any molecules to
deflect downward and therefore you
couldn't push the the wing up but the
fluid doesn't always have to be air you
might see similar designs underwater for
underwater drones it just has to be a
fluid that's passing by the object
[Applause]
okay so when you have this airfoil in
fluid when the fluid is not moving when
it's stationary then all of the fluid is
exerting pressure on the airfoil so you
get all these little normal forces
exerting pressure when the fluids not
moving and the airfoil is stationary in
the fluid then all of those pressure
forces all those normal forces or forces
perpendicular sum to zero because
there's no net force it's just sitting
in the fluid but when that fluid is
moving it generates a force so that's
the force it generates generally when
the fluid is moving forward force is a
is a vector so it has direction as well
as magnitude so they're the vertical
component and a horizontal component to
that so we call the the vertical
component the lift does anyone know what
we call the horizontal component drag
good job all right
now here's a here's a dumb question what
part of the aircraft generates lift yes
the whole aircraft a good job so a lot
of people might be under the
misimpression that it's only the wings
that are generating the lift
well actually the whole aircraft is
generating lift and it's not just
aircraft any objects that are moving
through fluid have have this phenomenon
and sometimes it's not a good thing so
what is this a picture of a race car
come on guys I know we're in an airplane
class but okay who can tell me what is
that thing sticking up at the back of
the race car a spoiler what's a spoiler
it spoils the airflow so when a race car
is driving on a racetrack and it's going
through the air that fluid is air
actually just the the the race car
itself is generating lift and that lift
can cause the racecar to kind of lift
upward and not be as much in traction
with the with the ground and when you're
a race car you want to go really really
fast you want to have very good traction
with your wheels against the ground so
you can go as fast as you can so the
reason that you have a spoiler at the
back is actually to counteract the lift
that's being generated by the racecar so
it's not just airplanes and and wings
that generate lift but really anything
moving through a fluid can generate lift
okay
so we're gonna talk a little bit about
equations don't get scared here we'll
just we'll just dive into it step by
step so we have F equals MA
hopefully this is not the first time
you're hearing about that equation all
right so can somebody just shout out
what is acceleration change in velocity
over time very good
so velocity again is also a vector so
velocity being a vector has both
magnitude and direction so you can
change the velocity either by changing
the magnitude or the direction in the
case of an airfoil we're changing the
direction of the air so the air has
velocity it's coming in we're changing
the direction of that air and that's
generating the lift so because we
changed the direction of the velocity
that creates a force that's our force F
so f is actually here representing the
rate of change of momentum above pushing
those air molecules down and generating
a force creating the airfoil to be
lifted up so that's why we discussed
again and that equal transit theory is
false because even an an paper airplane
with a with a completely flat cross
section of its wing as long as it's
inclined upwards such that the air is
being pushed down will fly okay so
here's another question which moves
faster the wing through the air or the
air past the wing
well you're very quiet which moves
faster yes the air over the wing we have
one for the air over the wing is moving
faster than the wing through the air
anyone else
yes depends on where on the wing you're
talking about yes as you find air to be
the air that's immediately thanks to the
like that is in contact with the air yes
so depends on which air you're talking
about okay true actually what we're
discussing is about frame of reference
so depending on your frame of reference
you if your frame of reference is the
airfoil you can take it to be that the
airfoil is stationary and you see the
air this the wing to be stationary in
the air to be moving past you if your
frame of reference is out here you might
see the air to be stationary and the
airplane to be moving through it so
depending on what your frame of
reference is you can actually have the
identical result so the answer is
actually that it's the same so depending
on your frame of reference it's exactly
the same the speed of the air moving
past the airfoil versus the airfoil
moving through the air and and the
reason so does anyone want to dive more
into that who are you guys familiar with
this concept of frame of reference yes a
lot of head nodding okay great so the
reason that's significant is that as we
learn about lift and as we study this we
actually could create a whole bunch of
different air foils and then build
airplanes and then fly them through the
air and measure them but that's very
expensive so instead what we do is we
basically we basically take the take the
airfoil and we put it on a stick and
then we put it inside a wind tunnel has
anyone been in a wind tunnel
got a couple people hey we saw that like
over 60 of you guys were aero-astro you
need to go to your Wright brothers wind
tunnel it's being upgraded actually
right now over in your building 33 so
because it's exactly identical the air
moving past the airfoil or the airfoil
moving through the air it's a lot
cheaper to put the airfoil on a stick in
a wind tunnel and then shoot air past it
and then do your measurements rather
than continuing to take off airplanes
and fly them through the air so we're
going to be talking about that a little
bit so the question is what what factors
affect lift so there are a lot of things
that affect lift so one has to do with
the object itself so I was talking about
the shape of the of the airfoil so you
know we talked about a different shape
which is just a flat piece of paper or
rectangle as a shape you can have a more
slender shape and the way that you
modify the shape can significantly
impact your lift so for example one of
the modifications can be back here at
the end if you made your airfoil longer
like this and point even farther down
then it would push the air in a slightly
different way so that would affect the
lift that that airfoil could generate it
would also affect the drag that it
induces okay another aspect is just the
size of the wing and the shape of the
wing so we see a lot of different kinds
so you know this is a big rectangular
wing in a jet you might see a swept wing
there are different types of shapes and
then there's also just the area so
regardless of whether you know if this
is your if you're looking down at an
airplane so this is kind of the broad
flat wings or you could have very thin
skinny wings that you might see on a
glider regardless there is a surface
area of the wing
area also impacts the the lift quite a
bit and and the aspect ratios we just
discussed and the shape can affect lift
the other thing other than the object
itself other than the wing itself motion
can affect lift so the velocity of the
air and the very importantly is what's
called the angle of attack so it's the
angle with which this airfoil has to the
air so if you had one airfoil that was
pointed kind of up like this versus one
the same one but it was not tilted up
this airfoil would be having a higher
angle of attack or angle to the wind
than this one now this might seem like a
very fancy description but who has been
in a car driving down the highway and
you've stuck your hand out outside and
if you tilt your hand up a little bit
you'll see that the the wind kind of
pushes your hand up and if you push it
if you tilt it down and you know your
hand pushes up and you kind of glide
your hand out the window so okay I'm
getting a lot of head nods so that's
really all that angle of attack is
talking about that if you if you angle
your hand up it gets pushed up a lot
more if you angle it down it gets pushed
down that's the angle of attack and
we're gonna define it more specifically
when we talk about the terms associated
with an airfoil and the shape but it's
good to get the general general concept
first okay and then another factor
affecting lift is the air the the fluid
that it's in so the actual mass of the
air flow coming around you so there are
a lot of aspects to that you know we
talked about whether you're in water or
whether you're an air or the density
density of the air another component of
that air is the viscosity does anyone
know what viscosity is
yes resistance to flow the way I like to
think about it is if you've ever baked
brownies and you have your mixing bowl
and your spatula in there and if you
just have you know the the water and the
oil and the eggs and you're mixing it
around you know you can you can mix
pretty quickly and it doesn't stick to
the spatula that much but if you were
mixing molasses or once you get all that
brownie batter in there it really it's
harder to do it and it sticks to the
spatula so that's what we're talking
about when we're talking about viscosity
so it's the tendency for these molecules
to stick stick to each other and just
stick to the object that's moving
through them so with the case of the
airfoil we're talking about and we were
discussing this just in just a moment
ago about which which air were we
talking about so some air that might be
very close might kind of stick to that
airfoil or stick to the wing versus just
moving smoothly past it so viscosity and
then compressibility also affects lift
so the compressibility of the air did I
turn off my mic all right
so certain types of fluids are
compressible so you could take a balloon
of air and you can move it into a cold
environment and have it shrink or in a
hot environment and have it expand while
having the same amount of mass inside
the balloon so I'm getting a lot of head
nods so that just shows the
compressibility of the air whereas some
types of fluids are not compressible
they're incompressible and they they
affect lift in a different way so
although I've told you all these things
that effect lift one thing I will admit
to you is that calculating lift is
difficult it's very difficult in fact we
don't really know how to do it properly
this is a snapshot from Wikipedia of all
the different theories of lift so there
are a lot of different ways that people
go about trying to calculate lift and it
turns out that it's very hard to do so
one that you
you see up there is is navier-stokes so
navier-stokes is a set of equations that
does a really good job of predicting
lift and it really it really takes into
account a lot of things it takes into
account conservation of energy
conservation of mass conservation of
momentum viscosity even a lot of things
like thermal conductivity and a whole
bunch of considerations but the the
problem is that solving those equations
is very hard you know we try to use
supercomputers to estimate every little
aspect and it's very difficult to do and
we're not really able to solve those
equations to determine precisely what
the lift is going to be let me talk
about some of the limitations that we
have in solving these equations so first
of all it has to do with how the air
flows over the wing if the air is moving
very smoothly past past the airfoil then
it's very easy to come up not easy but
it's easier to approximate you know we
can predict what a particular air
molecule is going to do but as you see
there when it starts spinning around and
becoming turbulent so if you start
seeing a particular air molecule that's
moving around and becoming turbulence
and not not doing laminar flow but but
turbulent and moving around and bumping
into other air molecules then predicting
what that molecule does and what all the
molecules do around it become very very
difficult in fact we have a very hard
time doing that and so instead we
basically assume that that doesn't
happen and and we propose limitations or
conditions on the air flow which are not
actually true but help help us with
approximating lift so one of those is
the Kutta condition that you see at the
bottom left which is this smooth flow
off so basically you say that
none of this turbulence is happening and
the air moves very cleanly off and you
also have a couple other specific
requirements such as that no air
molecule from the top comes over to the
bottom and no air molecule from the
bottom goes around to the top and you
just assume that they they moves
smoothly off and so that Kutta condition
is actually very helpful in in
approximating lift we also make other
assumptions that there's no viscosity or
that the fluid is not compressible
sometimes these assumptions are
appropriate and sometimes they're not
another thing that's really critical
about our ability to estimate lift is
that as I've been talking to you here on
the blackboard I have talked about a
cross section right that you just you
cut off the wing and you're only looking
at one cross section so since we're
talking about a cross section we're
talking in two-dimensional space well we
can actually do a pretty good job of
estimating lift in a two-dimensional
environment but the fact of the matter
is wings are not two-dimensional and the
wing comes out into the classroom and
back back into the blackboard and to
estimate actually how all these air
flows work at the edge of the wing is
very difficult has anyone heard about
tip vortices couple head nods okay all
right so we have a picture there that
shows a a jet to just show a little bit
about what the air does when it comes
off the edge the end of of the wing
we're going to talk about tip vortices a
little bit but the problem is that it no
longer is adhering to all of our
conditions now we don't have smooth flow
we definitely have turbulent flow we
have spinning flow and we have air
molecules hitting other air molecules
and it becomes extremely difficult for
us to model all of those air molecules
we really can't do it so so going from
two dimensions to three dimensions is
really a limitation of a lot of the
equations that we have to approximate
lift so what do we do well first of all
we go
to our two-dimensional surface and we
talked about all of these normal forces
so when you're you have all the fluid
going past has pressure and it's
supplying all these forces perpendicular
to the airfoil all around so how do you
approximate lift while you say oh that's
fine you just sum all those forces
around well that's great if you know
what all of those forces are but it's
not great if you don't know what all of
them are so what is the the solution
that we what we do basically we
calculate what we can and then we
measure the rest experimentally so in
this equation of lift for example so we
have Ellis for lift some of the the
other terms that you have there Rho is
the one that looks like a P so Rho is
talking about the air density you have
velocity and a is the wing area we
talked about and then we have this fancy
little symbol there C sub L or the
coefficient of lift and basically we say
that you know I don't know how to come
up with characterizing all those
complications about you know viscosity
and some of the the effects like that
have to do with turbulence and shock
waves Mach number Reynolds number all
these types of things and so we say you
know well measure what we can and then
we'll or will well calculate what we can
and then we'll actually in a wind tunnel
where we put this guy on a stick we'll
actually measure the coefficient of lift
and that's how we really calculate lift
these days is using a lot of measurement
to inform what's actually happening
because it's just very complicated you
know that velocity is squared right so
if you go twice as fast you get four
times as much lift that is the
relationship absolutely and the other
thing that's really important is that
that coefficient of lift is measured for
a given angle of attack so we talked a
little bit about angle of attack with
your hand outside the window so let's
get into
finding it a little bit more in detail
so in order to describe it I have to
come up with a few more terms that have
to do with the airfoil so we talked
about the very front of the airfoil or
the front the front of the wing is
called the leading edge and then the
back is the trailing edge okay and we
talked about the trailing edge a little
bit when we were talking about the
cutter condition that no air mall where
assuming no air molecule can cross the
trailing edge to the other side so then
the camber is in there so that's just
talking about really representing the
curvature of that airfoil and then a
cord line that goes in between so you
can measure how that is so try and do
your little zoom in fanciness that you
were doing I'll just point at it so this
is the cord line of the wing so you can
see that this is a full airplane that
the airfoil is right here and you see
this cord line going from the back to
the front
somebody trying to come in the door
there all right okay great
and then and we'll talk about some of
these terms one of the basically the
most important thing to think about is
the angle of attack thank you for for
checking on the door okay so talking
about how we can control the lift so
some of the things we can do have to do
with the aircraft design so we can build
an airfoil and we can talk about you
know how curved that airfoil is you know
the curvature on the top how curved it
is we can design the wing area when
we're flying we can control the airspeed
and then the angle of attack is
something that you can control when
you're in the airplane by kind of
pitching down or pitching up and well
will describe pitching and how you
control an airplane in more detail
another thing that's relevant is flaps
so I talked about in this drawing right
here where I added this white part of
the trailing edge that moves down that
really is kind of similar to flaps so
when your flaps are up they're sort of
in line with the rest of the wing but
when your flaps are down it's the
effective thing like pushing pulling a
piece of your trailing edge downward
which causes again more of that air to
be deflected downward so it increases
your drag but it but it also increases
your lift because you're deflecting more
air molecules down and then we also
talked about spoilers for example it's
something that can like on a car that
can actually disrupt the lift by
disrupting the airflow and when we
talked about the four forces of flight
if you're doing steady flight you're not
climbing or you're descending but you're
just flying straight that means that
your lift and your weight basically
cancel cancel each other out if your
lift is greater than your weight then
you can climb and if your weight is
greater than your lift then you descend
but if you're just flying straight
you're in an equilibrium where those two
forces cancel out okay so good I have a
more detailed diagram of angle of attack
so you can see here the cord line
you can also see the relative wind and
same things that I drew here the the
lift and the drag and then that
resultant force vector alright so you
can actually control the angle of attack
in a number of ways one of the the ways
that we talked about is is pitching down
so pushing your your yoke forward causes
the airplane to pitch down and it does
that by changing the elevator at the
back of the airplane we'll describe that
in more detail but the other things that
can affect the angle of attack you can
actually affect before you even take off
so it has to do with your aircraft
weight for example and the center of
gravity as well as your airspeed when
you're flying so here are a couple
diagrams that show you how the lift
changes with the effective angle of
attack and then there is a critical
angle of attack so that's when you know
you can be keep keep climbing for a
while but if you get too steep what
happens who knows what happens when you
go too steep you stall that's right so
the the air can't really effectively go
over the wing and it starts separating
and so you you're no longer effectively
pushing the air down and you lose the
lift that you were generating and one
thing I also want to point out here in
this in these diagrams is you see with
these little colored lines the air
that's just coming in and it's going out
and you can see that in this case the
the blue lines are showing that the air
that went over the top of the airfoil
went faster and actually got to the back
faster than the air that went from the
bottom so again please don't fall for
the equal transit theory okay so
practice question
okay a B or C Hey all right good so the
the angle of attack is defined there and
one thing that I would like to point out
is that this is also the case for a
propeller so your your propeller also
looks a lot like an airfoil or like a
wing that's sideways and and spinning
around and so also the angle of attack
for a propeller is symbol is defined
basically the same way is the angle
between the propellers chord line and
the relative wind
okay so let's define the center of
pressure so the it's basically the point
the point on the wing where the lift is
centered and so that can actually move
as you can see in this in this figure
based on the angle of attack the center
of pressure can act in a different
location and that's really important to
understand also that you know it's not
that the lift is always coming right at
the front depending on where you are it
might be pulling you in different
directions and that can affect the
ability of your aircraft and we'll get
into that in more detail so we talked a
little bit about flaps that flaps
actually can increase the lift that
you're able to produce but it it's a
trade-off because it also increases the
drag so when in the course of the flight
take off cruise or landing when do you
use flaps does anyone know
takeoff and landing landing yeah the
reason that you especially on on landing
many times people use flaps on takeoff
as well but the the reason it's just
that you like to have your aircraft
configure that in case you didn't take
off you can you can land without making
a lot of lot of dramatic changes the
reason that you do that is basically
that by increasing your lift but also
increasing the drag you know drag
affects you know how fast you're moving
forward right and so you can actually
have your the airspeed be be higher with
the ground speed being lower so without
what it does is it allows you to go very
slow without stalling and so that really
helps you land an airplane so basically
it allows you to come in at a kind of
steeper angle to land maintaining the
the airspeed that you need in order to
do that and you'll you'll notice that
there are different flap settings so you
can either have flaps it you know 10
degrees 20 degrees 30 degrees we'll
discuss that in more detail and Philip
will talk about it in terms of
performance I think as well thrust so we
talked about that forward force thrust
in this type of an aircraft a
single-engine propeller aircraft
it's the propeller that's rotating that
is really producing the thrust and it's
really as I said the propeller blades
are kind of like an airplane wing it's a
good way to think about it that are just
spinning round and round and in
generating lift but in this case it's
moving air puff fuels front to behind
your airplane and then although this is
also just a force instead of talking
about in pounds we usually talk about
the horsepower required to drive the
propeller so let me also talk about drag
so there are a couple different types of
drag so one drag is just what's called
parasitic drag or parasite drag it's
basically when the aircraft is moving
through the air that you get some kind
of resistance to that that's parasitic
drag where as this drag is induced drag
which is the drag that's created by
a lift so this this backwards D and so
you can see in this figure that the the
total drag is a sum of that induced drag
in the parasite drag we do we also call
the induced drag just lift in an
unwanted direction lift in an unwanted
direction
sure whatever can whatever can have you
associate induced drag with lift
that's the drag created by lift okay
ground effect does anyone know what
ground effect is only only a couple of
you all right so so let's talk about it
a little bit
so basically when you're very close to
the ground within one wingspan of the
ground you actually have some of the the
air flow going on with your airplane is
blocked by the ground and so you're
induced drag decreases now with the
induced drag decreases it's actually the
case that your airplane can become
airborne at a lower speed than it's
supposed to so what you might notice is
that when you're on the runway
taking off it's probably the first part
of your your flights after you did your
pre-flight your engine run-up your now
you pulled out onto the runway and
you'll have determined in advance what
is the air speed at which you should
rotate now that's really important with
a Cessna 172 for example it's around 55
knots and you want to look at your
airspeed indicator because if you just
feel yourself you might notice that much
lower like 40 knots that you the plane
has already taken off you're already
floating you're you're flying and you
might be very excited about that and you
might want to just you know pull back on
your on your yoke to take off well you
won't be able to sustain flight and and
so this is what why ground effect is
really important is that you can kind of
float over the ground because you're so
close to the ground that the ground is
blocking some of the
Effects of the air and so what you want
to do is really make sure that you
continue your ground roll continue even
if you're a little bit airborne stay
close to the ground until your airspeed
comes up to that rotate speed so in this
case 55 knots and then you pull back on
your yoke to takeoff
so again so when does ground effect
happen when you're close to the ground
when you're within one wingspan of the
ground okay so let's talk a little bit
about the stability and we'll start by
just talking about the three axes of
flight so there is a longitudinal axis
which is basically from the the nose to
the tail of your airplane and then
there's a lateral axis which is from
wingtip to wingtip and then vertical
going straight through the plane so you
have the ability to control all three of
those axes so the the elevator which I
keep talking about is like your yoke
where you push it forward or you pull it
back that allows you to pitch the
airplane so pitch nose up pitch nose
down that's you effect controlling the
back part of this tail the elevator
which allows you to have motion in this
direction so pitch nose down so you
might hear that a lot in case you're
getting close to stalling because your
angle of attack is getting too high they
might say nose down or pitch nose down
you also have a l'orange
which are out on the the side of your
wings and those ailerons control the
roll so that's rolling along the
longitudinal axis and then your rudder
which is at the back of the the tail the
vertical part of the tail that controls
yaw so this is called yaw this type of
motion so when you're when you're
turning you actually kind of do a roll
and yaw usually to in enacted turn okay
there are some cases where you actually
want to have adverse yaw or you you
actually adverse yaw means basically
you're you're using the yaw direction
and maybe the opposite direction at
which you're trying to turn with the
roll or other other angles of your plane
and so this just talks about an adverse
yaw is when you're you're not turning
the rudder in the same direction that
you're using your ailerons and so this
is where you talk about coordinated
flight or uncoordinated flight when
you're actually in an airplane the
rudder or the yaw is controlled by your
feet so you have feet pedals that
control the the rudder and your the yoke
that you're holding onto or a joystick
that you're holding on to front and back
controls the pitch and then turning it
like in a steering wheel of a car is
only controlling the roll so you
actually also use your feet for that
third direction of the yaw so just
talking about stability in general this
isn't going to dive into whole Diffie Q
discussion or anything but just in
general something that's stable so it's
just talking about like a little bowl if
you have a ball and a bowl even if the
ball gets jostled around it'll return to
the center point unstable would be the
opposite so if you have a convex surface
then if the ball moves even just a
little bit it'll really get moved out of
control so the reason that we talk about
this is basically when you're flying in
an airplane and you're talking about
stable aircraft for example the reason I
really love flying a Cessna 172 even
though it's kind of the the training
airplane is that the as people call it
it flies itself so if you notice the
planes doing something weird and turning
almost the best thing you can do is just
let go and the controls will normalize
and then the flame will fly straight and
level which is really great there are
other types of aircraft that are
inherently unstable so we have mean
she and Roxanna over here who have who
do Arab aerobatic flight and Mark will
be talking about that tomorrow so that's
where you actually want an airplane
that's not so stable so that you can
cause it to do all kinds of crazy
maneuvers and turns and twists very
easily you pretty much can't get a
Cessna to do that it really wants to fly
straight and level ok so then there are
also other aspects that can affect
stability such as your center of gravity
so how you how you load the airplane
will have a specific lecture that just
talks about weight and balance but one
thing to keep in mind is that you know
as people sit in your airplane or as you
put bags in the baggage compartment
you're loading the airplane and so if
you have too much weight aft of the CG
or behind the center of gravity you can
cause the plane to basically go like
this which isn't very helpful when
you're flying if you have things a
little too too forward it actually
pushes the the nose down in general the
nose down is a little bit more more
stable from the perspective of lift and
getting air to fly over you don't want
something that keeps trying to stall
whenever you let go of it and then
similarly you can talk about the
stability in the lateral direction in
that roll in the roll direction and some
of these things like swept-back wings
like you see on a jet can affect that
type of stability and then finally
there's a stability about the the
vertical axes generally this is going to
be kind of fixed for the given aircraft
that you're in but you can't affect it
as you design an aircraft so we started
talking about stall already so when when
you have your angle of attack past its
so-called critical angle of attack it
can cause the air to basically no longer
be able to flow over the top and no
longer be able to effectively deflect
air down and so the air air kind of
separates and you can stall so it's
really important to know that you can
actually stall at
any air speed even with full power you
can stall in fact one of the maneuvers
you'll have to do in order to get your
pilot's license is a power on stall so
you can stall both where your engine is
idling or coming in for a landing and
you you get to steep but you can also
stall with full power and you just you
just made your angle go too steep so
it's really affecting that that critical
angle of attack and again once you have
that angle of attack too steep then
there's a very significant loss of lift
which is not good when you're flying an
airplane so when can you stall at any
airspeed and any any power setting and
it's really based on the angle of attack
so if you
yes go ahead yeah basically it's not
generating any any lift right youyou can
see this like with a paper airplane
right sometimes if you it kind of stops
and kind of crashes we'll see how I mean
actually his paper airplane does here
well that one I definitely had a low
angle of attack so it flew very well
let's see if I can get it to stall or if
it's it's too stable of an airplane that
one basically after it's stalled it
basically went nose-down which is which
is good it has a little extra paper
folding at the front so that the nose
will will go down but it's really bad
basically if you if you stall it can it
can go that way the other thing that can
happen after you stall a lot usually is
you can enter a spin which is actually
the the next case so this is when you're
uncoordinated in your stall so what I
mean by uncoordinated so that's what I
was just talking about before where
you're your role and your yaw are not
going in the same direction and here you
can have a situation where both of the
wings have stalled so the airflow has
separated over both of the
but one maybe more stalled than the
other and it causes the airplane to have
a very very hazardous condition or an
intentional condition if your ox in over
there and you're trying to spin your
airplane to do a fancy trick is very
dangerous close to the ground as you'll
hear you only intentionally do this and
certain types of aircraft when you're
wearing parachutes in certain airspace
when you're very high above the ground
you don't want to do this and in fact if
you're just getting your private pilot's
license or your ppl you're not going to
you're not going to practice a spin
because it's pretty dangerous thing to
do in many aircraft but you do have to
learn about it and make sure you don't
get into a spin okay so let's talk a
little bit about maneuvering flight so
basically that means when you are flying
straight and level that's kind of when
you're in equilibrium where your lift
and your weight kind of cancel out and
the planes just going straight and level
at the same altitude but climbing is
when your lift temporarily exceeds the
weight so you can actually climb so once
you are in a steady climb then you can
actually still have your forces be in
equilibrium so remember F equals M a so
a is acceleration which is a change in
velocity so if you're not changing your
velocity and you're just in a steady
climb then you're also not accelerating
now there this is a little bit
complicated so I will say this is a
little bit tricky there is a tendency
for these airplanes to turn left and
there are actually multiple things that
contribute to this left turning tendency
and when you're in an airplane flying
you might hear hear your instructor say
right rudder and it's really to
counteract some of these left-turning
tendencies so we're gonna break break
them down and talk about them but this
can be a very in-depth subject so I will
definitely refer to the P hack which is
the pilot handbook of aeronautical
knowledge chapter five goes into all all
of these
so the first one is torque so basically
the thing is when you're if you're
sitting in the in the airplane and
you're looking forward at your propeller
most US engines actually have the
propeller rotating clockwise so with and
you can see that arrow that says action
so that's the propeller rotating
clockwise and so because of the because
of Newton we know for every action
there's an equal and opposite reaction
so because the propeller is turning to
the right the whole airplane is trying
to roll to the left so that is the first
left-turning tendency
before we move to the next one are there
any questions on this left turning
tendency
okay great so the next one is P factor
which is an asymmetrical thrust this
happens when the airplane has a high
angle of attack so either when it's
climbing or in this condition called
slow flight which is where it's kind of
an uncomfortable thing you have to do
this in your flight training so
basically you have your your power
setting pretty high but you've kind of
pitched the airplane up and so you're
not getting as much air flow over your
control surfaces like your ailerons and
your elevator so it's they call your
controls mushy so it's hard to kind of
coordinate your airplane but you kind of
sit in that in that environment to
basically understand how it's difficult
to control the airplane in that
environment so if you're pitched up and
you have a so you have a high angle of
attack and you're either climbing or in
slow flight you have this tendency where
the because you're angled to the wind
the right propeller blade which is
descending is kind of cutting into the
air that's coming in so it's actually
generating more thrust whereas the
ascending left propeller blade so the
propeller blade that's going up on the
left side is kind of coming away from
the wind that's coming at it and so it's
not generating as much thrust as the
right propeller blade so that causes the
center of thrust to move towards the
right and that
creates a little bit of a yaw tendency
of the airplane does that make sense
great a lot of head nods P factor was
one that both Philip and I spent quite a
bit of time getting our heads around and
professor hansman helped us out there so
another one is called the corkscrew
effect sometimes it's called slip stream
or spiraling slip stream it basically
has to do with the fact that that
propeller remember it's just kind of
like a wing that's spinning around and
so it is it's basically push you know
pushing the the air back and since the
propeller is spinning around that air
that's coming back from the propeller is
spinning around the airplane and as it
spins around when it comes up to the
back it pushes on the vertical
stabilizer that tail piece and causes
causes the the plane also to do a left
yaw does that make sense some good head
nods yes why doesn't it also cause it to
you roll was the question
and it could especially if it's hitting
hitting the wing but in general what
we've seen is that you know and it can
depend on whether you're in a high wing
or low wing but the the biggest thing
that it sort of hits is here now in
general when you get a left yaw you you
sort of kind of roll these are these are
connected angles but I think just what
we've observed is primarily that the air
when it hits the vertical stabilizer is
the biggest surface that's kind of
pushing it and the angle that it's at so
if you sum it all together yes I'm
actually quite confident you'll get some
roll but the biggest thing that you
notice is the yaw
okay so let's see if we we understood P
factor as well as we think we did
okay a B or C eh all right good job I
actually have my little hint there that
the B is actually talking about torque
which is a different left turning
tendency and then finally we're going to
talk a little bit about gyroscopic
precession is a little bit complicated
if you're not familiar with the
gyroscope but when Phillip talks to you
about all the different controls in your
airplane you'll have to learn about
driver scopes all over again and a
little bit but in general what do you
need to know about a gyroscope you know
what is a gyroscope gyroscope is
something you can hold it's spinning you
can you can play with them what they
allow you to do is have rigidity and
space and they also have this concept of
precession and precession is basically
that the the resultant action of a
spinning rotor when a deflecting force
is applied happens 90 degrees ahead of
that rotation and so because of that you
can consider that the you have the the
propeller spinning and that causes this
driver scopic precession and that
basically causes 90 degrees out of out
of that sink is this force which causes
kind of a young movement of pitching and
a young in this case
once we talk more about gyroscopes and
how they work you'll also learn
different flight controls that you look
at in the plane leverage leverage these
gyroscopes and we'll come back and
circle back to making sure we understand
the key fundamentals of gyroscopes yes
sure so let's go back to P factor so
what we're talking about is the
difference in the center of thrust so
the thrust you know when you're when
you're straight and level the thrust is
just forward but what we're seeing is
that when the the right blade because
when you're in a high angle of attack
the right blade is generating more
thrust than the left blade so the center
of thrust is slightly to the right so
that is why because it's to the right
and not up or down up or down would
cause a pitch up or down but since it's
to the to the right that's why it's
causing the yaw action so precession is
separate it is generating its own
factors and dynamics so both of these
things are acting at the same time so
precession does in fact affect pitch
just like you correctly recognized but
this is an additional factor that's
happening is that since the center of
thrust is actually moved to the right
it's causing the young did that answer
your question
No
do you want to chime in Phyllis it's an
external force as opposed to generated
by the propeller it's a it's a little
bit it's a little bit tough I think yeah
we should table it and and refer you to
that physics book see how it flies which
has some of it but the one thing I would
add on P factor is another thing to keep
in mind is whether the propeller is
advancing or retreating into the wind
so if you think about it when the
airplane is level the propeller is not
moving relative to the the oncoming wind
but if you tilt the airplane up as the
propeller goes down it's actually
advancing into the wind and getting a
little bit of an efficiency boost that
way whereas when it's coming up it's
going from the front of the airplane
towards the back of the airplane so it's
retreating yeah so what Philips
describing is why the why the right
propeller blade is generating more
thrust in the left propeller blade which
is what's moving the center of thrust so
I think the think the real thing to
answer your question is that there's
more than one effect happening
simultaneously yeah
I'm not sure that you get gyroscopic
precession from that action here because
it's generating the lift by pushing air
I'm not sure that all the thrust really
has to go through for P factor at least
through the center of the spinning
propeller also I know in helicopters in
you know the like physics 101 answer is
90 degrees but the real answer for
engineering it is 72 degrees so it does
get complicated fortunately it's beyond
the scope of what the FAA tests you on
because they themselves I'm sure don't
understand it fully yeah how about we
come back after we've talked about
gyroscopes in excruciating detail and
then we have a set of terminology to
talk about let's come back to discussing
that more things
yes just remember I hope she's happy
power or propeller so the the P is
referring to that propeller want right
propeller more than the left it also
usually happens when you're at a higher
power so some some flight instructors
like you to think about when you have
higher power and the airplane you'll
need to put on more right rudder to
counteract that left-turning tendencies
I actually almost done so I think we can
finish there so so one thing is to type
it so we talked about with climbing
flight you know F equals MA so once
you're done changing the velocity and
you don't have a change in velocity your
forces are in equilibrium so the same
same is the case with with a descending
flight when you're actually turning your
forces are not in equilibrium because
you're having this change in velocity
and so the you actually have a number of
changes happening and it's basically
considered accelerated flight which the
same as you know when you're driving if
you if you're turning so when you're
flying when you're doing a turn you're
accelerating because you're constantly
changing the direction of your velocity
you also have load factor which we'll
get into in more detail when we talk
about performance of an aircraft and how
the load affects your performance but
another thing to think about back when
we were talking about that zero gravity
flight and a plane flying in a parabolic
trajectory or a rollercoaster when
you're at the top but when you're at the
bottom of the rollercoaster you really
feel like you're being pressed down into
your seat in fact when you're we were on
that zero gravity flight although at the
top we had thirty seconds of
weightlessness so we could do our
experiments when you go to the bottom of
the parabola you basically get two G or
twice what you normally feel and so you
have to kind of lay down and and let
that happen before you come up again and
so when you think about load factor just
think about you being at the bottom of
your roller coaster and really feeling
kind of twice that
force on you and then just to kind of
end we want to talk about you know most
of the time we're talking about the
planes that you be flying but another
type of aircraft all together is a
blended wing body aircraft so just like
this is one example of that so it's what
it means is that that fuselage or that
kind of tube in the middle that you sit
in is blended into the wings so that the
whole you know whole body is generating
more lift because the whole surface is
kind of designed that way it's really
kind of cool
and from an aerodynamic perspective it's
it's got a much better lift-to-drag
ratio because you know the whole thing
is really deflecting that the air
molecules downward and generating that
lift so I just ask kind of a thought
question if this is so much better it's
more efficient of an aircraft and
aerodynamically has much better
properties why do you it actually we've
also found that it's you know better in
terms of fuel efficiency because it has
less drag and more lift why do you think
that you know JetBlue and American
Airlines don't fly aircraft that look
like this
they don't have routes with a thousand
passengers well you could make it you
could make a smaller a blended wing body
aircraft yes passengers like windows
that's actually a big it's a big reason
truthfully yes it's very different from
what's currently made and they said so
the development would be very risky
actually I think it's more than just the
development because it's different from
what's currently made the entire
infrastructure supports the current
format of an airplane with a tube and
wings so we're talking about airports
jet bridges the way that people load
food carts onto a plane the way that
passengers get on and off the fact that
passengers don't have as many windows on
this type of aircraft it's unfortunately
that whole infrastructure that surrounds
it that is a big contributing factor to
why even though there's a better design
why we don't move towards that so this
was a big big thing for me when I was an
undergrad at MIT
you know aero-astro I'm thinking I'm
gonna design the next best amazing
airplane but even if you do design the
next best amazing airplane it may not be
widely deployed because of these other
infrastructure aspects which really got
me into systems engineering but enough
with that thought exercise for time
we'll just summarize you know what did
we learn today so we talked about how
does an airplane generate lift and we
talked about different factors that
affect lift we also discussed the lift
is very hard to calculate and so we
experimentally measure a lot of aspects
of it and we discuss the different
forces on an airplane stability and kind
of this left-turning tendencies and some
of the different aircraft configurations
so are there any questions about that
yeah okay what do you think about what's
two questions let's take the bathroom
break and then yes you think about I'm
gonna call the pizza people and give
them my credit card
you